Detroit is a place of like innovators
creatives it's a great place to come and
start over again I think it's definitely
important for people who belong to that
community to kind of help rebuild it
[Music]
during the crisis and during the
foreclosure and a bankruptcy of Detroit
a lot of people lost their homes and
moved out unfortunately within the area
the city is not building any new homes
by activating these vacant spaces and
transforming them into urban farms or
beef farms were able to have vast
amounts of fresh vegetables that are
bees and our partners can cross
pollinate to provide for the community
[Music]
what we do is transform Detroit vacant
lots it's an urban bee farm
[Music]
all my life have been born and raised
here in the Motor City my grandmother
will always create home remedies
whenever me my brother would get sick so
when I got sick and dissembler I went
back to those methods I came across the
power of local raw honey from a local
store in Ferndale Michigan when that
word it like we quit like okay this
study more about this honey and its
medicinal properties since we started it
has been the year the yes
opportunities come we say yes and it has
helped us get to this
[Music]
we're definitely changing the typical
stereotypes of beekeeping particularly
here in America typically don't see too
many beekeepers of color by my entries
I'm gonna help inspire others that they
can do the same thing it's important to
expose our children to something they I
know they're not familiar with for one
we never know where it might take them a
lot of these shows you've never even
seen the honey come before and they have
very little knowledge to be so it feels
great to educate them on the importance
of honeybee conservation growing up as a
kid it wasn't cool to be into science or
to keep bees or to be outside in nature
so we really did see a lot of those
positive figures of people out there so
I think it's important for someone like
me to be in a position of leadership to
inspire other people that it's cool to
learn about science it's cool to give
back to your environment and your
community when people find out about our
organization they're like wait you're in
Detroit the shock value when we get
people when we tell them that we're
beekeepers I look at its wife
you don't have to have a million dollars
and your bank account exciting idea go
for it starting a nonprofit organization
within the community it helps inspires
others to feel that they can do the same
thing it's important to pass on this
education to our generation so they can
create a better future for themselves
there was a problem that we see in our
city there was a problem that we see
with our honeybees what we're doing here
is solving both of those problems
[Music]
you
[Music]
you